if a person robs you on land they are a
thief but if they rob you at sea
they're a pirate
let's say it's 2007 and you're the
captain of a cargo ship traveling off
the coast of the Horn of Africa
you're transporting wheat from Kenya to
Saudi Arabia
when you look out at the ocean and you
see these guys
they come at you quickly just a small
speedboat of them and soon they're right
up against the side of your ship they're
about to throw a ladder to climb up
oh
you run into the ship Citadel or safe
room and you call the Coast Guard or
maybe you try to spray them with this
water hose to scare them away but it's
too late they've now climbed on board
they're rounding up the crew they're
gonna hold you hostage and demand a
ransom of millions of dollars for anyone
who will pay
shipping company or home government your
family doesn't matter
and if you don't give them the money
you'll be held in captivity starving
maybe even tortured for days weeks
months even years there's no answer to
payment of the ransom within three days
then
um the kidnappers here will sell me
will sell me to al-shabab this happened
hundreds of times
this is what a typical hijacking in this
region looked like in the early 2000s
where by the end of the decade hundreds
of piracy incidents were reported every
year and they were still just getting
started
so let me show you how the Horn of
Africa became the epicenter of modern
day piracy and how what started as
Somali fishermen defending their Waters
turned into an organized criminal
Network
and fall of Somali pirates
were those pirates attacked that vessel
[Music]
with irrational people back this book
against the War I don't know what they
are able to do
okay A little sidebar really quick
um yes I'm wearing my orange jacket
inside because it's kind of cold in the
studio anyway one of my least favorite
Parts about living in the internet age
is how tracked I am and how tracked we
all are I spend a lot of time on the
internet and when I do that all of my
data all of my browsing behavior my
purchase history my address my social
security number my location history is
scraped by some shadowy company and put
onto a list and then bought and sold in
an open market this is why my inbox is
chaos why my phone is always blowing up
with Robo calls why I'm constantly being
marketed to and sent stuff to my house
that I don't want it's a nightmare and
it's getting worse every year people's
data is being more and more exploited
not just by marketers but by recruiting
companies and financial companies and
risk management companies and people
search sites so that people can search
you it's like not cool luckily we all
have rights to get ourselves off of
these lists the problem is no one's
going to spend the time going through
the bureaucracy to actually get yourself
off these hundreds of lists that you are
probably on and that is where incognity
comes in Incognito is the sponsor of
today's video as you probably have
gathered and I'm very grateful to them
for sponsoring the video and supporting
our journalism but also I'm grateful
that they exist because I didn't know
about them until they came to sponsor a
video and now I'm a super fan you sign
up for incognate and you give them
permission to go out on your behalf to
take you off all of these lists when I
signed up for it they were able to scan
and see that I was on dozens of lists
over a hundred lists and they were able
to show me what lists I was on it's all
in this nice looking dashboard and then
the best part is you get to sit back and
watch incognate do all the work for you
go and fight to get you off all of these
lists sometimes that's as easy as just a
little request that they do and they get
you off the list sometimes they get
pushback from the company and they will
do that fight for you until you are off
that list
and you just get to sit back and watch
it happen I'm really glad that they
invented this because it has been
getting out of hand like we love the
Internet it's great but like this data
exploitation thing is getting out of
hand and I swear someday we're gonna
look back on all this and be like that
was the Wild West for now incognate is a
great tool to protect you and protect
your privacy so there's a link in my
description it's incognito.com Johnny
Harris click the link you help support
the channel but you also get 60 off
their annual plan why do you need an
annual plan because when they take you
off a list inevitably if you continue to
use the internet you'll end up back on
that list incognate constantly monitors
month after month to make sure that you
stay off of these lists soon your inbox
will not look like pure chaos your phone
will quiet down mine sure has and you
can rest easy knowing that your data
isn't just out there searchable by any
Corporation or person who wants it so
the links in the description thank you
incognitive for sponsoring the video
Let's dive into this big topic of
pirates
pirates are aren't one thing they've
always existed as long as there's been
international trade on the ocean there
have been pirates Sailors who utilize
the expanse of the open ocean to Rob and
steal and run sophisticated businesses
if you haven't seen cgp Gray's Deep dive
on Pirates go watch it it's a two-parter
Pirates are everything from Norse
Sailors who raided other ships on the
high seas to the famous Pirates of the
Caribbean like Britain's Blackbeard who
stole a French slave ship and souped it
up into the ultimate pirate vessel
Pirates were poor men who were looking
for money and social Mobility some of
them were looking for fame and glory and
Power in a time where seafaring men had
little status or opportunity in society
we've romanticized them we've
caricatured them and we idealized them
as Legends and myths of the past but
piracy never fully went away it's still
very much exists today
here's a map of all the piracy incidents
over the past 40 years at least the
reported ones from Indonesian Pirates
hijacking cargo ships in the Strait of
Malacca to Bangladeshi Pirates holding
fishermen hostage in exchange for
ransoms all the way to West Africa where
Nigerian Pirates steal oil off huge
tankers and sell it on the black market
but most of the dots on this map are
right here the gateway to the Suez Canal
one of the busiest highways of global
trade off the coast of a country where
piracy uniquely could thrive
the government of Somalia collapsed in
the early 90s
the country fractured and instead of a
central government local Clans started
to control patches of the country there
was no real government to regulate this
3 000 kilometer Coastline the longest
coastline in Africa
as a result huge fishing boats mostly
from Iran and Yemen took advantage of
this free-for-all swooping in to these
unregulated Somali Waters to fish
these foreign fissures would steal
hundreds of millions of dollars of
seafood every year with Nets that tear
up the sea floor destroying the
ecosystem and depleting the fish stock
in the process
this illegal fishing by Foreign vessels
started to outsize the catch of locals
whose water this was local Somali
fishermen with their tiny boats couldn't
compete and soon this illegal foreign
fishing eclipsed the catch of local
somalis
around the same time companies from
Switzerland and somali's former
colonizer Italy were illegally paying
corrupt factions of the Somali
government to take their toxic waste
some of it even being radioactive
tons of this waste ended up in both
somalia's land and water which would go
on to have significant effects on the
health of local communities
foreign
[Music]
so it's the 1990s and between the
illegal overfishing and the waste
dumping Somali people's main livelihood
is being pillaged by foreigners and they
don't really have a government to help
them out to protect them so some somalis
decided to fight back an American cargo
ship taken over by Pirates Somali
fishermen got together and they formed
an ocean militia some would call
themselves The Coast Guard and they
would use these tiny boats to chase down
foreign fishing vessels and demand that
they pay a fine some experts have called
this subsistence piracy because it was
piracy but it was also kind of fishermen
defending their livelihood from
predatory foreigners and at first it was
rare I mean if you look at the data you
just see a handful of successful
incidents every year oh and they were
pretty basic too
like in one of these early incidents of
Somali piracy back in like 1994 you've
got this Wooden Boat full of 26 Somali
men claiming to be the Somali Coast
Guard and they go up to a shipping
vessel and they get on board they like
hijack it for five days but realize they
can't really do anything so they just
steal as much as they can from the cargo
ship and just go on their way
yes this was piracy but it was super
basic and kind of harmless it was a
bunch of locals filling in on the power
vacuum left by their non-existent
government and this is how it was for a
long time Loosely organized gangs of
armed Somali men climbing aboard cargo
ships or fishing vessels intimidating
the crews to collect fines or sometimes
asking for informal license fees for
fishing in their Waters even though they
didn't have any authority to give out
licenses they did it to get money to
basically like if you're gonna fish in
our Waters you need to pay us and the
rest of the world didn't really know
about this it like wasn't big enough
news for anyone to care but that would
soon change
across the region eighty thousand people
are dead at least 22 000 of them were
killed here in Sri Lanka so there's kind
of a turning point Christmas 2004. this
tsunami was devastating mostly in
Southeast Asia but it also hit somalia's
really delicate Coast destroying homes
and boats and crippling an already
delicate economy and food supply the
tsunami took the lives of some 150
people in Somalia and poisoned the
precious little water supply that people
had here and it also washed up some of
that toxic waste that had been dumped
off their Shores this led to a U.N
investigation which concluded that the
waste was likely causing severe damage
to the health of local people and at
this point Somalia still isn't one
country there's some parts of the
country that are peaceful and safe and
undergovernment control but most of
Somalia is still a patchwork of
competing Clans and Warlords a hotbed
for terrorism and organized crime
networks that control different parts of
the country
and piracy this thing that started off
as an informal Coast Guard was maturing
in sophisticated ways
[Music]
by 2005 you start to see Pirates using
motherships larger ships that allow them
to go way further off their coast and
then to use speed boats to attack like
they did to this cargo ship this was a
huge level up for Somali pirates
these motherships started to be equipped
with radar which allowed the Pirates to
have new ways of detecting their prey
you start to see them have GPS systems
or satellite phones to communicate
Pirates start looking at shipping
industry blogs and databases to locate
and track shipping vessels this was
turning from basic subsistence piracy to
something more sophisticated Pirates
started to realize just how much money
and value was flowing through this
Corridor headed towards the Suez Canal
like one of the busiest highways of
international trade in the world and
with these new and improved tactics came
more profitable business models that
would change everything for pirates
police in Finland say the owner of the
missing freighter C has received a
demand for a ransom it was the early
2000s and it was the beginning of the
era of ransoms you were kidnapped by
Somali pirates and you were held hostage
for more than two years hey Michael it's
Johnny Harris
good to hear from you so we had a really
interesting conversation with this
American journalist named Michael Scott
Moore he was kidnapped by Somali pirates
and held for almost three years before
being released for a 1.6 million dollar
Ransom
[Music]
turning to piracy ransoms changed
everything
Pirates were realizing how easy it was
to hold a ship hostage and to demand a
multi-million dollar Ransom to extract a
huge profit which attracted the
attention of Warlords who saw a business
opportunity Warlords now wanted to fund
hijackings like this one where Pirates
were hijacking a Ukrainian coal ship
that was traveling from South Africa to
Turkey
they could hold it hostage and release
it only in exchange for seven hundred
thousand dollars which is what they got
or another instance were pirates riding
on speed boats captured this Japanese
ship and its 20 person crew holding them
hostage until somebody coughed up two
million dollars there was investment in
these pirate operations because there
was a return to be had and by 2007
around 30 percent of the world's pirate
attacks occurred within this circle
but wait let's keep this in perspective
this actually wasn't particularly high
if you look at a graph of all of the
other regions of the world you'll see
that this wasn't by any means an outlier
but Watch What Happens the next year
this line going up represents the
expansion of the piracy industry in
Somalia
there was way too much money to be made
here and Warlords were getting better
and better at investing in and running
pirate businesses by 2009 this body of
water off of Somalia was home to nearly
half of all piracy incidents on Earth
and look at this graph of the average
ransoms paid in 2008 the average Ransom
was a million dollars a total of 30
million dollars was paid out that year
and you got to keep this in perspective
these were huge sums of money for anyone
but especially poor fishermen turned
pirates in a country with a GDP per
person of 517 dollars per year but even
still this was just the beginning if you
simply refused to pay I mean the Pirates
have a lot of hostages
uh the consequences of of those being
shot for instance would be unimaginable
all of this influx of Ransom cash kicked
off a pirate economy cycle where Pirates
would attack a ship hold the crew
hostage and get paid a high ransom they
would bring this back to the clan leader
warlord who funded them which would make
that person rich and allow them to
invest in bigger boats and more guns and
recruiting more young men and appeasing
the local Coastal communities who would
support them which they would use to
hijack more ships in more sophisticated
ways and it repeated and repeated
getting more and more sophisticated and
dangerous each time so a businessman who
gets to be so rich that he needs to
protect his business interests with
gunman
that's a work and a a pirate boss is
nothing else he's a he's a businessman
who invests in piracy the pirate
businesses had lawyers and cooks and
banknote tellers with machines that
could detect fake bills so that they
could know if their Ransom cash was real
or not there was this great reporting at
the time in 2009 by Reuters one other
journalists went to a pirate town that
had been a sleepy fishing Village but
had turned into a booming pirate Hub or
in their words pirate Lair what Reuters
found was that this economy was so
booming that they had created a stock
exchange where any local in the town
could invest what they had into a piracy
business there were dozens of these
piracy businesses and you can invest in
the one that you think is gonna go get a
successful Ransom by hijacking a
international shipping vessel and people
made a lot of money one local said they
made 75 000 in just a couple months
because they had made a good bet on the
right pirate pirate bosses were not just
you know top Pirates they were investors
who had a portfolio of businesses
these pirate businesses would in turn
support these communities help fund the
schools and the hospitals in order to
Curry favor with the locals to make sure
that they would support them running
their businesses but the people who are
really getting rich here were mostly the
clan leaders the Warlords who were
building massive Villas and buying
luxury cars and throwing lavish
drug-laden parties
this was no longer the DIY Coast Guard
this was now lucrative organized crime
and yet some of these pirate groups
still tried to make a moral case as to
why they were justified in doing this
saying that this wasn't piracy this was
retaliation for all of the exploitation
of Somali Waters by foreign countries
foreign
you see this in a 2008 hijacking of a
Ukrainian vessel when these Pirates
demand eight million dollars claiming
that they would use the money to clean
up the toxic waste that European
companies had dumped in their Waters yes
European companies have dumped toxic
waste in Somalia were these Pirates
actually going to use the 8 million
dollars to clean that up probably not at
least that's what we found in our
reporting a lot of the moralistic like
Robin Hood narrative became really thin
once Warlords got involved and once they
demanded a return for their investment
and you just start to see how thin this
moral argument is when pirates start
boarding ships and just shooting crew at
random to show how serious they were and
to increase the likelihood of getting
high Ransom payout unfortunately the
uh there is one statement from Mainland
which was who was killed by by the
Somali pirates or when they started
hijacking U.N ships that were full of
food and Medical Aid meant for Somali
people the ship apparently was bound
from ambassa Kenya and the shipment
included vegetable oil corn soy blend
and other basic food commodities Bound
for people in countries including
Somalia Uganda and Kenya this was about
money and power and it was able to
thrive because of a country that didn't
have a government that actually
controlled the country by 2011 there
were 237 piracy incidents here over 1200
hostages were taken that year 35 of them
died while in captivity this was
becoming more and more deadly and more
and more lucrative let's go back to that
graph of the average ransoms that were
paid you can see it grow up to around 5
million dollars for the average Ransom
the total number of ransoms paid in 2011
100 150 million dollars
it was getting out of hand but it would
take a few key events for the world to
really take notice
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen all ship stay
inside stay inside stay inside we are
trying to stay a shotgun try to run away
from them now stay inside everybody this
is a real alarm please stay inside
there's this funny thing in
international news where in order for
the world to take notice of something it
sort of has to affect like westerners
and that's no different with pirates
there was this one incident in Fall of
2005 where a group of pirates showed up
to a luxury cruise ship it's full of
Western tourists they hit us with
rocket rocket grenades RPGs
[Music]
there was a woman in her cabin
and she was fortunately in in her
bathroom but a rocket grenade went right
through and through the whole cabinet
the cruise ship escaped but it still led
to global news coverage
another incident was in 2008 when a
Ukrainian ship was hijacked by these
Pirates
little did these Pirates know they had
just stumbled upon a shipment of tanks
and grenades and ammunition Bound for
Sudan they were demanding 35 million
dollars to give it back holding the crew
and the ship hostage the U.S and Russia
both freaked out here and they sent in
their navies to like monitor the
situation to make sure the Pirates
weren't going to take the weapons off
the boat in the end the Pirates agreed
to a 3.2 million dollar payout and the
secret weapons shipment continued onward
it was a big scare and it was another
step in waking the world up to how big
of a deal this was becoming but the
biggest event happened a few months
later
a U.S container ship was traveling from
Oman to Kenya when four Pirates boarded
and hijacked the ship holding the crew
hostage and demanding two million
dollars
the US government has a firm policy that
it doesn't negotiate with hostages but
what they do do is send in their
military
so after four days the Navy Seals
arrived with snipers they shot three of
the four Pirates and rescued the crew it
was an incident that was later depicted
in this Tom Hanks movie
these were dramatic events a hostage
situation with snipers and Navy Seals
and it spread into the international
news cycle in a way that Somali piracy
just hadn't before but Captain Phillips
was taken hostage for almost five days
and then rescued by the U.S Navy it was
clear that this had become too lucrative
of an economy there was too much
incentive for Warlords to get in on all
of this money for it to stop the only
way to slow this down was a serious
intervention
as we were reporting this story I kept
asking like why is this such a difficult
problem to solve and we asked all of the
experts we interviewed and we have a
pretty good idea now why this is way
more complicated than expected first off
guns you can't really carry guns on
international shipping vessels partly
because there's International gun laws
that are complicated partly because
shipping companies don't want guns on
boats because it can be a weird
liability thing you can't just have like
a gun in a safe box somewhere second
it's hard to send in the Navies to
patrol these Waters because Pirates
often don't look like Pirates until it's
too late at which point they're prone to
use their victims as human Shields
against any threatening Navy so unless
you've got like the best snipers in the
world like the Navy Seals it's actually
really hard to use just like military
force against these Pirates and lastly
you have to remember what we're talking
about we're talking about the open ocean
huge swaths of water it's really
challenging to Monitor and control this
in an effective way it's one reason why
piracy has always thrived on the open
sea but even despite all these
challenges governments and businesses
put their heads together and they
figured something out the first one's
kind of boring it's this report that
this international shipping organization
put out that basically teaches ships and
captains and companies how to protect
themselves they recommend them using
this high pressure hose that allows them
to just like spray water at the Pirates
they started recommending putting barbed
wire and razor wire around your ship
kind of gnarly put locks on your doors
increase your surveillance like this is
pretty basic stuff create a safe room or
a citadel where you can like lock
yourself in if you get hijacked one of
the big things they did was create this
internationally recognized Corridor
where ships could all travel together
like in a caravan sometimes escorted by
a Navy ship from one of these countries
helping them navigate this really busy
but very vulnerable part of the
international shipping Highway and
another huge step was in spite of all
the complicated gun laws vessels were
now allowed to employ armed guards to
stand watch as they navigate these
Waters so now you've got like security
guards with guns on the ship who have
nothing else to do but like protect the
boat and guess what all of these
strategies totally worked I mean look at
this graph after its all-time high in
2011 hijacking incidents plummeted
because of these interventions
but this leaves us with kind of a
complicated resolution here these
communities were left behind by their
government they don't have the
infrastructure of a society where people
can Thrive and work that's for a lot of
reasons but it's in part because of the
pillaging and the exploitation from
Outsiders and so while these Warlords
who committed horrific crimes to get
rich deserve no moral justification it
is morally complicated when you look at
people who are just trying to live whose
Waters have been poisoned by toxic waste
whose country has been pillaged and who
turned to piracy as a last resort but
I'm not going to go into the ethical
dilemma here I think you all can fight
that out in the comments if you want
um I'd love to see what you have to say
the fact is piracy was solved in the
Horn of Africa because of these
interventions at least for the most part
but just as Somali piracy was declining
incidents of piracy he started popping
up on the other side of the continent
the Gulf of Guinea took somalia's title
as the piracy hot spot of the world
these attacks happen for different
reasons and they look quite different
they're usually Nigerian Pirates
boarding oil tankers to steal the oil
that they feel like was stolen from
their land the International Community
is now turning its focus here and this
is a more complicated thing to solve for
a lot more reasons the fact is piracy
won't go away as long as the ingredients
that have always fueled it exist
frustrated young men with no chance of
finding work in an economy incentivized
and organized by Clan leaders looking to
get rich on the high seas operating in a
gray area where the government and the
society that should support them and
employ them doesn't exist or is too weak
to help leaving them to fend for
themselves and to turn to more and more
sophisticated forms of crime in the
process
foreign
[Music]
hey everyone
um look at this map behind me I don't
know if you caught it during the video
but this is a map of
uh mostly of East Asia but you get this
um Somali peninsula
and the Gulf of Aiden and basically
everything we've talked about it's all
right here it's really a beautiful map
and when you look at it you can see just
how
important this Suez Canal is to global
Shipping anyway
um
yeah I this I've wanted to look into
Somali pirates forever like I've thought
I've always saw the news over the years
and never really understood the the
story The the background and
we reported on this and we talked to a
lot of experts and there's actually a
lot of politics in this
um there's a lot of people
who argue for like a Vindication morally
of Somali pirates saying that they're
just retaliating against a a world who's
who's exploited them and like that's
there's a strong argument there
um
but I don't know again I'm really
curious to hear what what people have to
say about it yeah we are interested in
making deeper and deeper
videos like this a video like this takes
much more time and resources to like
really understand to get the data like
we got this whole data set that we used
to map you know every incident like
that's just like a way bigger thing
um
but we want to do more of these so I'm
curious to hear from you
um what stories we should do next for
those who want to support this effort of
making high quality factual videos uh we
have a patreon it is called The Newsroom
that is what we call it and it is a
place where you can support with your
money to help
make possible what we do here you can
also buy Luts and presets which are the
things that we use to color our videos
to make our videos look beautiful like
this and not like this which is what it
looks like when we shoot it I have a map
poster that we sold out of but then I'm
pretty sure we reprinted it like a
thousand more so that should be in stock
don't quote me on that it could be sold
out again by the time you're watching
this I have no idea yeah go watch search
party which is our new channel that is
created by my old box colleague and now
my partner Sam Ellis who is building
that channel but sort of under our
broader company here and it's awesome
and it is rigorous and amazing and
really good journalism it's called
search party it is here on YouTube
um and I think that's all the things I
need to tell you about here in my little
cozy
couch setting it's so dim in here I feel
like I could just take a nap on this
couch and I just might so thank you all
for being here and for the support and
the kind comments and the appreciation
and we will see you soon in the next one
bye-bye
thank you
[Music]